the Mass Effect games have always let
you choose between playing male or
female but Andromeda has a great reason
for that choice I'm Tony and this is
your space faring GameSpot news updates
Mass Effect Andromeda hero is commander
Ryder as it turns out the male and
female versions of rider are actually
brother and sister so both exist in that
universe not only that but the character
seen in the very first trailer is
actually the rider siblings father all
of this was confirmed by creative lead
Mac Walters who also stated that there
will be more information on the Ryder
family in the future it'll be
interesting to see how their family tree
affects the events of the game Mass
Effect Andromeda is coming to ps4 xbox
one and pc by the end of March 2017 we
just saw some new gameplay at the
PlayStation meeting and a new trailer
has been promised for november seventh
better known to Mass Effect fans as n7
day for all the biggest Andromeda news
you're already in the right place